[Music]
by way of introducing Robert I had Danny
Hillis on our board wrote me a note he
said he had met Robert and said his that
science that he's working on is really
interesting and that piqued my interest
and then probably to other people sent
me separate notes and I was like all
right well I gotta go figure this out
and and generally when someone said
they're freezing brains I'm like I'm not
paying attention to that
and so but this one I was like okay well
enough people I trust are telling me to
pay attention and so I made an
appointment and we and I went down and
he walked me through the experiments he
was doing and and I was really blown
away and I think both by the the work
that he's doing and his background as
well as the the implications of it which
I know that we're gonna want to talk a
lot about tonight so with that welcome
Robert McIntyre
[Applause]
well good evening everyone
I salute you all for being here tonight
and I'm very excited to speak with some
people who think about the long term I
consider myself an archivist and what I
work on archiving is human memories and
so we'll get into the technical details
shortly but I want to spend a little bit
of time for saying why do we care about
archiving memories and for me personally
the reason that I care about this comes
from how I view history so I see human
history as being divided into different
stages and we advanced from one stage to
another by the invention of technologies
that are better able to preserve
information from one generation to
another and every time we invent a new
technology that can preserve information
it radically catapults our society to
new heights so you know originally we
have no language we have no writing it's
more of an intuitive or animal era of
history so imagine that you're you never
learn how to speak like your parents
never teach you because they don't know
how to speak imagine how that would feel
that you have these thoughts in your
head that aren't even in language
because you've never learned to think in
those terms and they're trapped you
can't communicate them all you have to
go on is your instincts that you're born
with and your personal experience that
you accumulate through your life that's
just a totally different existence
that's that's probably so different it's
almost impossible to even imagine what
it would be like at least for me I think
in terms of language it's hard to even
know what would be like to never have a
word your entire life and I would say
this is more of an animal mode of
history but then we invented language
and so language is a technology that's
able to preserve information from one
generation to another now instead of
having your thoughts trapped in your
head you can talk to someone else so you
can hear stories from your ancestors you
can hear what people seven generations
ago we're talking about you can hear
about imaginary things and so we
mentioned of language catapulted us to
the era of oral history and that's the
difference between us being animals and
the difference between us being able to
conquer a large part of the world
so you know it's a huge advance but just
language alone and having an oral
civilization is very limited in a lot of
respects because you are limited to what
you can actually remember which is very
low bandwidth so the next technology
that we invented to preserve information
is writing which we use writing so much
it's it's hard to remember just how
magical it is but if someone you know
imagine that we didn't have writing
before and someone said these words that
I'm speaking that are ephemeral they're
gone as soon as they're said we're gonna
figure out a way to carve them into
stone and they're gonna last longer than
a person can live you'd say well you
don't understand what words are like
that that's the same that's impossible
how can you make an arbitrary symbol
mean a sound right and in fact we didn't
invent language all once we've been at
partial scripts that were dealing with
mathematics do it with numbers of things
and then it took a while for people to
figure out oh you could say anything and
write it down so what if you have
language and you have writing then you
have the era of written history and
that's the era that we're in right now
and it's hugely beneficial you're able
to have libraries full of things that no
one person could have in their head all
at once and that's what's powered our
modern civilization but writing is still
missing a lot of things you know
consider what the difference is between
living through a war and reading about
that war in a history textbook I would
argue the majority of the value of that
first-hand experience is actually lost
when it's written down certainly it's
better than not having writing at all
but you lose quite a bit I'd say we lose
most of the important bits in particular
we lose the wisdom that we generate it's
not because wisdom is magic
it's just wisdom has such a high
dimensionality to it that it can't be
linearized and written down in a form
and then read back it's very hard to
learn wisdom by reading you sort of have
to live it and crystallize your life
experience so if I was going to predict
what the next information preservation
technology is going to be it would be
the
to capture the things that writing
doesn't capture wisdom first-hand
experience these sorts of things
I think the invention of such technology
will catapult us into a new era of
history called the era of living history
the difference being if you're in the
era of living history you can talk to
someone who was alive and actually had
first-hand experience of it so that's
the question I try to answer how can we
preserve living memory and by the end of
this talk my promise to you is that
we'll have gone over these four pieces
and you'll see how they fit together to
achieve what I think it's possible it's
a day to actually preserve living memory
and it's got four parts it's got
information theory clinical science
neuroscience and the technology of
preservation so we'll go through each of
these four parts quickly and information
theory we're going to learn about what
it means to preserve things in a little
bit more of a rigorous way we've all got
a intuitive understanding of what
preservation is and we're going to learn
how to think about it a little bit more
rigorously and how to think about it for
things that you might not fully
understand like DNA or books written in
a language that you can't read what does
it mean to preserve those things how can
you know whether you preserve those
things by this talk you have a better
idea of that we'll talk about some of
the clinical science which I find very
fascinating and we'll cover a surgical
technique that I think it's the most
dramatic surgical technique in the world
that most people haven't heard about
we'll go through the neuroscience will
briefly cover the science of memory
consolidation what our current top
theories are for how memories are
actually created in the brain and then
we'll round it up by talking about
embalming technologies and talking about
chemical preservation methods and how
they're tied to spices what you might
get a new appreciation for so let's
start with information theory so we got
the I on the bottom that's kind of a
checklist rate of the talk what does it
mean to preserve something all right
well we've all got an idea of what it
means to preserve something those books
right over there are currently doing a
fine job of preserving the stories
that's contained within them but I'd
like to explore this intuition with you
for a little bit and so let's play the
preservation game I'll say some things
we could do to these books
and you raise your hand if you think
that it would preserve the information
of the stories that are in the book and
intuitively alright so raise your hand
if you think the information is
preserved here's the first one we'll
just leave them on the shelves for one
day and then we'll look at Anna many do
you think that would preserve the
information in the books and raise your
hand you think that it would so you
don't think that that would preserve the
information why is that for one day so
tomorrow that those books won't have
their information no no I mean will the
information still be there tomorrow ok
so if we if we do it to them does it
another way I think if we do this to the
books does it destroy the information in
them ok so leaving them for a day we all
understand intuitively that that's not
going to do anything to the information
that's that's stored them ok so number
two we're gonna burn them and scatter
their ashes to the wind so no one will
ever see them again how many of you
think that will preserve the information
in the books no one thinks that will
preserve no one believes that the books
somehow live on maybe ok
no ok all right let's say that we do
burn them but we buy new copies of the
books and we put them in where they were
before and they've got the same letters
in them as the original books how do you
think that operation preserves the
information in library yeah all right
not too much sense mentality in this
crowd ok we're gonna do wrote 30 now
what is wrote 13 it's a simple form of
encryption so take your letter you move
it 13 spaces forward you wrap around if
you run out of spaces so if you take the
interval it becomes some pure Virginie
okay if you take Grif our journey what
does that become what do you think the
interval right because it's reversible
so let's say we were to wrote 13 all the
text in all the books does that preserve
the information or not everyone you
don't think it preserves the information
what do you think what's that yeah if
you wrote through teen something that's
already been wrote through team that
undoes it and you get the text back yeah
so it's reversible so it's got to kind
of preserve it because it seems weird to
say the information is gone when you can
do something to it and get it back well
it clearly wasn't gone if you can get it
back right okay now let's say we mixed
up some clear epoxy and we poured it on
all
books okay and that epoxy is going to
soak into all the pages and it's gonna
glue the pages together and it's going
to render the book into a solid form of
plastic okay and you'll never be able to
open the book again but the epoxy
doesn't make the ink smudge at all it
doesn't make the run in fact it glues
the ink even harder to the page than it
was before
do you think if we were to epoxy all the
books over there that that would
preserve the information contained in
them
well does the information does the
information being preserved depend on
the existence of a technology or not
does the information become preserved
after you invent the technology or was
it always preserved even before you met
the technology exactly but it would have
been preserved in respective of the
technology that exists right it doesn't
retro actively make it be preserved
because you've invented a way to scanner
okay so all right great so what's the
principle here what's the common
principle behind our intuition why do we
think the burning destroyed the
information why do we think that the
epoxy preserves the information even
though you can't open it right why do we
think the encryption preserves it well
for that we need to turn to information
theory very light information theory and
the concept of an injective function
all right so injective function is the
one on the Left non injective function
is one on the right what's the
difference between two well this one
keeps different things different but
this one does not keep different things
different three and four become the same
thing so in the case of burning the
books it's not objective because if you
have a pile of ash you can't tell
there's many different books that could
have made that pile of ash you can't
tell which one which the wrote 13 is
injective because you can always tell if
there's two different books and you
apply the preservation to them then it
keeps that difference all right so that
leads to our first gold star idea here
which is preservation means that
different things stay different okay
that's what it means to preserve
something no matter how you transform it
as long as in all cases if the things
are different you maintain those
differences you will have preserve the
information that's what means preserve
information and that leads us to our
second idea which is interesting that
you don't actually have to understand
what you're preserving in order to
preserve it for example I can't read
Chinese but I can preserve Chinese books
by using the EPOXI method because I know
that if they were different Chinese
texts that the ink would be different
and I know that the epoxy doesn't alter
the ink of the pages and so different
texts will make different plastic epoxy
blocks so this also applies to things
like DNA you don't we were able to
preserve DNA even though we don't know
what the DNA
means as long as you know that it's not
going to change the letters of the DNA
any questions so far
yeah what's up
well we'll do that we'll do a loan app
that you have to have boundary
conditions so it's a little do light
information here here okay so moving on
so we know that if you're gonna have
information preservation it means you
keep different things different okay
within a finite bounded volume of space
and time which is why you don't have the
quantity that is okay so now we're gonna
move on to clinical research okay
and this is one of my favorite clinical
surgeries and nobody knows about this
for some reason but the question is if
we could preserve brains now we know a
little bit more than me so you means you
have to keep different memory states
different after you apply our
preservation process but the brain is a
really complicated dynamic system like
my brain has a lot of electricity
running through it right now and a lot
of chemicals running through it right
now and it's alive stuff moves in it so
you might think if you stop that
movement you stop that electricity then
well what does that dude was that erase
the information in it or does it not
matter
by default it seems like maybe the brain
works like a computer and a power outage
if you turn the power off to it you
would lose the information you know
documents are open that you haven't
saved for example and so the question is
our memories store an electrical
activity right the actual functioning of
the brain well how can we figure that
out I think there's very powerful
evidence that it's not that comes from
clinical science so back in the day
maybe a couple hundred maybe a hundred
years ago doctors noticed that sometimes
people will fall into frozen lakes you
know they have thin ice you fall into it
and they'll drown in the lake it'll
literally drown to death in this lake
and they'll sit there for an hour and
you can fish the person out of the lake
and in the state they have no brain
activity
they have no heartbeat there's no
circulation there's no breathing there's
no electric chain in the brain there's
no electric tivity in the heart they
feel cold to the touch they really look
like they're dead
and yet in some cases if you warm them
up just right they come back to life and
they function again
with varying degrees of damage depending
on how they drowned so doctors notice
that this happens sometimes and they
thought they could take advantage of it
by creating a technique called DHT or
stands for deep hypothermic circulatory
arrest you see there's this problem
where if you need to do surgery on the
blood vessels of the brain or the main a
or tech arch we know how to do those
surgeries they're actually quite simple
the problem is the blood is flowing
through these vessels and if you try to
do the surgery then you're going to have
blood go everywhere you're going to have
the patient die and you basically can't
do the surgery fast enough even though
you would know how to do it to save the
patient's life very unfortunate these
doctors notice you cool people down they
said well what if we did that
intentionally under a controlled
situation so that we could make it so
that the patient is cold and now their
blood isn't flying now you've bought you
know they can stay under the lake for an
hour sometimes survive that so you've
got an hour to do your surgery and then
you warm them back up and maybe someone
who would have died because you couldn't
figure out how to physically do the
surgery could instead live so the
sixties they invented this technique and
it works quite well so they did a study
for professional people to see if there
was any change in their memories after
cooling them down with this process and
warming them back up and the exact
meaning of these is not so important
it's comparing people who had DHD a
first people who did not have the HCA
and it's judged by their boss and by
their family in this case and they just
sent a questionnaire that does the
person seem different in any way than
they were before and they asked the
family I don't know this dad seemed like
you forgot some stuff and basically just
said no so it's quite amazing but one of
the very rigorous principles we get some
clinical sciences that memories have to
be durable and physical constructs
whatever they are and they clearly
survived a shutdown a total shutdown of
electro activity okay so we know we need
to keep different things different we
know memories have got to be some type
of physical
question is what type of physical thing
are they - that we need to turn to
neuroscience so let's go for what's our
current theories of how memories
actually work so how does it bring
create memories well our current theory
of neuroscience is this idea of memory
consolidation right and this has been
created over the last forty years with a
lot of heroic efforts in molecular
biology and neuroscience and so we've
found that memory consolidation has
three components to it essentially three
different time scales on which it
operates the first one is a minute or so
one one second 30 seconds 60 seconds and
that really is controlled by the
electrical activity in brain so think
you're memorizing a phone number and
you're trying to dial it in or the exact
words that I've just spoken to you kind
of linger in an echo in your head for a
little bit but then you mostly forget
you don't remember exactly how I
introduced myself for example so that's
the short term and we don't really care
about that too much now you have this
process that takes one to two hours that
is kind of an intermediate process where
there's been some changes to synapses
but the changes to those synapses are
kind of liable by default they'll revert
back to their original stage this by the
way is the synapse so synapse is a
connecting elements between neurons they
used to communicate with each other and
synapses are quite complicated
constructs but they can change their
size and they can either do that
temporarily or they can do it
permanently the temporary version is
this one a two-hour part then you've got
more than two hours and if you're going
to remember something and you're able to
remember it for more than two hours it
generally is encoded as a long-term
memory and it'll stay with you
potentially your entire life and when we
look at what happens in the brain we see
that the synapse is actually physically
changed actually changed their size when
a memory is created so what does that
look like well it looks like this so to
provide the context here these white
blob things okay are these right
this is about as good as can be done
with light microscopy and what you're
looking at here is an actual living
neuron a tiny part of the living neuron
and the synapses that are attached to
that and you're watching learning happen
here so this synapse in particular is
going to enlarge so you see that this is
before learning and then after the
learning it's bigger and then over the
next two hours you know it maybe reduces
the size a little bit but compare this
one to this one and you'll see that it
got bigger now synapses can decrease to
look at this one here and look at the
corresponding one they're smaller and
the same thing with this one that one's
kind of small but it barely exists here
so this happens in thousands of synapses
throughout your brain even to encode the
most trivial memory if it's actually
going to last for longer than two hours
when principal the brains that is quite
distributed you can destroy any one
synapse it doesn't affect anything now
what does this Maps actually look like
they're very very complicated all right
they're very small your brain is about a
liter of material and a synapse is about
a femto liter of volume so think about a
trillionth of a liter and then divide
that by a thousand and that's the
femtometer okay and so you have a
quadrillion synapses in your brain and
so they provide the scratch space that
you need by changing their size to store
all of your memories and even within
that femto liter volume you have about
40,000 proteins and those proteins do
various jobs like moving vesicles around
to release neurotransmitter being the
ion channels that control the strength
of the setups and doing all of the
housekeeping maintenance to keep that
synapse live and then also to be able to
change the size so very complicated
constructs but the main takeaway is that
if you're going to create a long-term
memory you undergo the process of memory
consolidation and every consolidation
changes the size of synapses and
changing the size of synapses requires
protein synthesis we know this because
if you inhibit protein synthesis
you can't consolidate memories anymore
it's actually kind of a weird effect you
can be under the effect of a protein
synthesis
inhibitor and your short-term memory
work Lyoness electrical your medium term
memory will work fine that's still
doable because it doesn't require
protein synthesis but your ability to
encode long-term memories is compromised
people have a very high alcohol
tolerance can get into this mode they
call blackout drunk and a person can be
functional they're blacked out not
because they're unconscious but because
they're not encoding memories properly
and so you can actually have crazy
situations where you could write
yourself a letter or you could hide
something somewhere while you're under
the influence of this you wake up the
next day you actually genuinely surprise
yourself and communicate with yourself
this way so we know that you have to
keep different things different if you
want to preserve information we know
that memories we've got to be physical
because clearly they survive a shutdown
and we know that if you're going to
encode a memory you've gotta change
synapses so how does that come together
to preserve memories well that's why we
have to talk about embalming and the
question clearly is can you preserve
synapses because if you could preserve
synapses you can keep different memory
states different so can we preserve
synapses well the answer is yes we have
long ago figured out how to preserve
synapses since the 60s with a very
special chemical called blue door
aldehyde now you might recognize the
name glutaraldehyde sounds kind of like
formaldehyde right and so you know
formaldehydes use an embalming
glutaraldehyde often is - although it's
not talked about as much and the way
that it works is it's like a pair of
molecular handcuffs so each of these
ends on here called aldehydes and it's
got two of them and what it does is it
can cross cellular membranes and it can
grab those proteins so all those fancy
proteins right there
the glutaraldehyde enters it's much
smaller than that and it glues them
together it gels them together into a
solid gel and traps them so they can't
move anymore and it traps all the
proteins into this gel and so it's
really quite effective at preserving the
structure of a synapse if you look at
the protein content before and after
preservation it's identical and here is
what I consider a tour de force image
from a
very amazing paper where they did living
imaging of a living neuron and then they
preserved with glutaraldehyde and they
picked out exactly the part that they
preserved and they did electron
microscopy on it so this is what it
looked like when it was alive and you
can see the synapses at the limit of
what you're able to see on a living
neuron then they looked at with a lot of
microscopy and you're about to see what
it looks like after its preserve
occluder aldehyde and image at a much
higher resolution it looks like this and
so you can see that every single synapse
here is preserved every single one of
them this looks exactly like just a
higher res version of this neuron which
is amazing you know you've got a
quadrillion synapses but if you have one
chemical that can glue all the proteins
that they're made up together then it
sort of doesn't matter how many synapses
you have as long as you can provide that
evenly to every synapse so
glutaraldehyde is clearly able to
preserve synapses that's why I've been
using it for half a century to preserve
synapses ah so these are the four pieces
right you have this requirement to keep
different things different and you have
the knowledge of what differences are
when you create a memory and you have a
incomparable preservation technique
that's able to actually preserve it a
much higher level of detail that is even
required if you imagine two copies of
yourself right that are exactly
identical to each other in every way
down to the molecule with one exception
that one single synapse is one of the
brains of the people is changed it's
erased or it's enlarged and you imagine
what glutaraldehyde preservation would
do even the difference as subtle as that
would be preserved by glutaraldehyde
fixation
if you imagine two organisms that had
one single actual memory different
that's going to be thousands of synapses
at the very least not just one synapse
and so of course glutaraldehyde would be
able to keep those separate as well so I
think the analogy here is with DNA DNA
is something that we've only recently
scanned so the first human genome
project wasn't 2003 and we were able to
scan the entire human genome that great
expense out of curiosity when do you
think we knew enough about DNA to
preserve the DNA any guesses come on
somebody be brave what do you think what
year do you think we knew enough about
DNA that we could preserve it not scan
it what's that yeah 60 so 1959 we
discovered the structure of DNA and once
we discovered the structure of DNA you
can make a very straightforward chemical
and thermodynamic argument that liquid
nitrogen can preserve DNA alcohol can
preserve DNA all kinds of things can
preserve DNA and so there were 50 years
there where you we were capable of
preserving DNA but we weren't capable of
reading that DNA but nevertheless I
think there's a compelling argument to
be made that we should preserve the DNA
of species that are going extinct from
the 60s to now because we can eventually
read the DNA and I think we're in the
same place today with neuroscience that
we were with genetics in the 60s we know
enough about memory that we can
confidently preserve it but of course
it's quite difficult to actually do
anything with preserved synapses because
there's an awful lot of them but
nevertheless I think that this
technology is the first in a series of
pipeline technologies that will
eventually lead us to a new era of
history the era of living memory
[Music]
thank you Robert
and I think that was a I'm really glad
you added slides to this by the way we
walked through this earlier he did a
fantastic really fantastic job I think
of getting us to kind of where we are
now in this science of understanding
that we can preserve memory yet not
necessarily understanding what we're
gonna do with that memory if we were
going to do it but I wanted to get a
little bit more of your background I
know that one of the ways into this came
from your work in in the brain
preservation prize and so when you say a
little bit about what you thought your
insights were it from what I understand
it's from combining a few different
Sciences that people were too
specialized to understand but I'd love
to hear you say a little bit more about
that absolutely so I've always been
interested in how you can preserve the
information that stored the human brain
and originally I thought that that would
be done through just a straight
application of neuroscience and so
that's kind of what I studied for in
high school and what I do what I
imagined I would be doing with my career
and then I realized that you know
neuroscience was making a lot of
progress but it was nowhere near at the
level that it could actually read
information out of a human brain and it
probably wouldn't be for a generation or
two and so I transitioned from that to
doing AI research because I actually
thought that you know the AI would get
you there faster there's always a
tension when you're trying to solve a
really complicated problem between do
you attack it with the tools that you
have right now or do you build some
better tools even though it takes you
some time and then attack it with better
tools and end up solving it faster than
you would have if he just started in on
it and I thought that reading
information through human brain was one
of these problems that probably need
better tools to do it so I was doing
that but then I found this brain
preservation prize so this was the first
rigorous sign
we based attempt that I'd ever seen to
actually preserve the information of the
brain and I found that to be very
compelling because generally preserving
information is a lot easier than
manipulated information or reading that
information and so there was this prize
called the brain preservation prize and
it would be awarded to the first team
that could preserve an entire mammalian
brain and argue they could keep it
preserved for at least 100 years and
verify it with electron microscopy so I
started volunteering for them and in the
process of volunteering for them I just
want to make a youtube video that would
like you ever see minutephysics you like
it'd be a little cartoon that would say
here's the prize your competitors for
the prize here's like what they're
trying to do there's why they haven't
won yet here's the next steps right but
in the process of researching that
cartoon I was like yeah I think I can
just win this prize instead and I just
left the AI research and made something
that could actually win it and so it's
based on glutaraldehyde fixation but
glutaraldehyde fixation is very good but
that gel isn't stable for a hundred
years and so to that I added this
antifreeze approach from chronology that
allows you to convert the gel to a glass
form and the glass form is stable for a
hundred years
stable for a thousand years no problem
so that's kind of the journey up to now
well and the I mean I think what's what
is interesting here is I you know I mean
to thousands of years ago we've
preserved information on stone that has
lasted for thousands of years and
hundreds of years ago we started with
books which has lasted for hundreds of
years I think it's funny that we're now
preserving things in digital formats
which are questionable they're somewhere
between five years and and kind of zero
depending on you know how good you are
with your backups copy them makes them
for everything else that's really quite
cool yeah so the digital information
unlike those other things that have much
higher copy ability I mean what does it
take in order to like for instance to
win that prize so what was the what was
the level of technical and like I mean
how many dollars per brain do we does it
cost right now to preserve a brain down
to the synaptic level the majority of
the cost would actually be s'long term
storage right now the actual
preservation is fairly
inexpensive and it's it's a minor change
to process we've been using in
neuroscience for 60 years but the
samples have to be maintained at
negative 135 degrees C which is quite
inconvenient of a temperature and so
it's just expensive to do that but the
annoying part of it is if you want like
dry ice temperatures - 79 C that's easy
we have refrigerators that will do that
or you can use dry ice you want to go
down to like - 190 degrees C liquid
nitrogen will do it but there's no
cooling agent that can do - 135 that
isn't also explosive so hydrogen like
entertain and stuff will do that it'll
catch on fire and that's not good gotcha
and so the what do you think was the in
winning the brave preservation prize I
mean were you was this largely an
insight of a single type of science or
combining sciences and so the siloed
sciences weren't getting there and by
being able to combine them that was
helpful yeah so there were two groups he
had a group of Germany that was working
on doing electron microscopy of entire
brains and so they were using a
traditional glutaraldehyde fixation and
then they were trying to convert the
brain to plastic using actual epoxy and
then in the plastic form yeah it would
be stable for a hundred years but they
had a lot of trouble getting that
plastic to penetrate into the grandness
it's quite difficult but they had no
problem
rapidly stabilizing the brain in a form
that was good for at least a few months
then you had the traditional cryobiology
approach which was focused more on
maintaining the biological viability of
the brain kinda like with organ
preservation and so their problems
always been that they can't stabilize
the tissue fast enough to preserve it so
you both you get the long range
stability afforded by the prior
protection you get the short range
stabilisation reported by the fixation
so the brain has a vascular system to
provide the question is are you freezing
the brain or slicing it up um so the so
a fixation can be done on slices and be
done at whole organisms even the process
is basically the same as embalming
you're using a circulatory system to
deliver chemicals to every cell in the
body almost instantly what's that so I I
care about so that so the question is
well wouldn't the next have to be to
reverse this process of fixation and I
would say maybe not I care about
archiving the information and so you
know if i was i've almost in the
position of like a museum curator well
hold on we're gonna get to questions in
just a minute so we're gonna we're gonna
use a microphone so that everyone can
hear them as well as their online
audience but what we're yeah so we're
getting there don't worry
yeah so the i mean i think and this i
think this fits into the question of
like how do you I mean how do you see
this work that you're working on and I'd
love to I know that you have a few
slides on showing some of your work and
showing a physical memory and how you
preserve it so I want to show that but
like how do you see this kind of fitting
into this larger arc of you being an
archivist and wanting to archive memory
and and I know that you have some
thoughts about how this what the next
steps are and how far away we are from
something like being able to recover a
brain and what the at least what those
steps may be so let's let's revisit this
book that's been trapped in this epoxy
if you were charged with getting the
story back out of it right after it been
sitting around for a hundred years and
you're given a budget of ten million
dollars to do it how would you guys
approach it any any thoughts yeah
good approach so you would put that in a
micro CT machine and the you would be
able to literally see into the plastic
and get a complicated digital image of
the book and then you could go through
that and you could extract the letters
and you could print a new copy of the
book and there you save that would only
really cost you maybe a hundred thousand
bucks or something maybe even less maybe
twenty thousand so you pocket the rest
that's a good choice another option
would be you know you get a really fancy
slicing machine that's able to cut that
preserved plastic block into very very
tiniest slices there's blades that can
cut a piece of paper edge on a thousand
times so if you could do that then you
would be able to easily take a picture
of each of the slices and reconstruct
the book that way too so when I think
about where the future of technology is
going for interrogating brains I'm
looking at connectomics research so in
1980 or so I'll call me on that one like
we scan the whole C elegans connecthome
300 neurons
10,000 synapses total in the worm so a
small project took him 10 years today
you could do it in like two months
just last year we scan the fruit fly
connect all 40,000 neurons
I think a hundred million synapses
something like that very impressive took
them three years took them a couple of
million dollars but that's cool now
there's talk of doing an entire mouth
spring okay a hundred million neurons in
a mouse brain an entire third of a
milliliter in volume okay so that's not
quite within striking distance of a
human brain which is a thousand
milliliters but it's you know a huge
increase and they think they can do that
for only three hundred million dollars
so and only in five years so it's a nano
scale so so you can see individual
vesicles it's down to the neuron yeah
that's right not just down the neuron
down to the individual
pieces of the synapses of the drive
that's correct so if you extrapolate out
when do we get the capability to scan a
leader of material that nanoscale
resolution it's like 40 to 50 years like
like 30 to 50 years
whether that's truly enough to access
all the information that's required who
knows if you really press me on I
generally say it's it's the work of two
generations about 70 years to I think be
able to access information in brains but
I don't know one of the things that we I
mean we talked about I think which is a
good example as they the work that was
being done at that at the San Diego
frozen zoo and when that started so so
the San Diego frozen zoo started in 1972
so we understood enough to preserve DNA
in 59 so 13 years later they were like
yeah let's preserve DNA for species that
are about to go extinct and I thought
that was really quite brave of them to
do that because at the time they could
have been criticised by saying we will
never have a gigabyte of storage so
you'll never be able to store DNA ever
okay and even if you did have a gigabyte
of storage it would cost 100 million
dollars and you can't scan the DNA to
put it on there anyway because that
would be a trillion dollars with the
current technology and it'd take a
hundred thousand years literally like
that's about what it'd be and yet the
first human genome was then scanned
forty years later for three billion
dollars and ten years today you can scan
a genome for about a thousand dollars
and it takes about 24 hours and DARPA
now has a challenge program for the
first group that can scan an entire
genome for less than a dollar in less
than an hour which lots of companies are
seriously competing for and they think
that they'll have that in a few years so
it seems almost unimaginable to think
that you could scan a whole leader at
nazca resolution but there's there's
certainly no physical reason why we
would feel
and could you walk us through a little
bit on the the experiments that you
showed me at your lab you have no lights
so so a question is can we get any
memory right if you're trying to
preserve DNA you know maybe you could
read one base pair at least just as a
kind of a proof of concept and so one
thing that we're working on is these
model organisms that are these C elegans
so here is the learning model that we're
using alright so this is a worm and it
crawls around it likes to eat its ecoli
on its plate and what we do is we tap
the plate so you know they're in this
little petri dish and if you go it like
makes earthquake for them and if they're
naive and they haven't ever felt the
earthquake they freak out they do this
so here we're gonna you see that a back
saw way quite a lot you saw the
vibration you saw that it backed away
okay now here's a naive worm
alright here's a tapped worm okay so
this one's used to it it's been tapped
over and over and over again let's see
what this worm does so it's moseying
long Seagate stuff and now we're gonna
deliver a tap to it it doesn't really
care okay let's see what his friends
think so here's two more and we'll give
them a tap that was just moving that
wasn't the time we're gonna get my time
okay yeah a little bit of movement kind
of half-hearted and then it gets right
back to eating so this is a memory you
know this is something that that's the
most primitive form of memory a
habituation memory but it is a memory
nonetheless and the question is how does
the elegans encode this memory well
steal against nervous systems pretty
simple you've got you have all right so
you have the brain at the front of the
worm and you got like another brain
kinda at the back of the worm and we've
got some stuff and it's like spine and
this is the ones that we're using in our
lab but as it's been reported in
literature before there's a difference
in the ion channels in these synapses
along the tail of the worm so here is
reported for tapped worms and here's the
naive worm so you can actually see the
difference between those synapses and so
in theory you should be able to take
these worms and look at them after
they've been fixed with preservative
chemicals and read out at least the
state of whether they are habituated not
directly from examining the nervous
system what's your to get away with in
this case because we understand the
nervous system well enough to know what
this particular collection of synapses
it's for the worm in most cases you
wouldn't be able to do this so this is
like a proven concept extracting one bit
of memory from a ceiling that's worth
that we're currently working on don't
look at that one don't look at no don't
look at that one
that was nothing okay and one of the
things you mentioned where's spices and
the kind of the spices that are
effectively are being used for
preserving grains well we didn't talk
too much about that so all right so you
know then so again we got glutaraldehyde
we got formaldehyde guess what another
word for vanilla is vanilla aldehyde
guess what another word for cinnamon is
cinnamaldehyde another word for cumin
cumin aldehyde right a lot of spices
just are aldehydes and the reason
they're used like with the Egyptians to
preserve meat is because they can fix
and and and partially damaged pathogens
your pathogens are not going to be able
to reproduce as well if they've been
partially embalmed by preservative
chemicals so and in fact things that are
aldehydes tend to have a little bit of a
fruity smell to them and glutaraldehyde
formaldehyde or no exception to it
they've got their own unique sort of
spice like type of smell now occluder
aldehyde smells
you know people describe it differently
maybe like rotting pumpkins maybe like
overripe apples I don't what do you
think it smells like rotting apples yeah
and then formaldehydes got a very very
light almost airy sort of fruity smell
to this very subtle
so that's your spices and is that what
the sorry I just came back from Egypt
not too long ago so were the Egyptians
using some of these spices Egyptians
take the brain out because all the
lipids can easily become rancid then
they dehydrate as much as they can and
they throw a bunch of salt and then they
use some spices and all of that was
trying to get rid of much water as you
can and then try to like make it
chemically hostile to anything that
wants to
like mold cool alright so we're pretty
good we're getting very quickly to the
point where you can ask questions so we
have a microphone somewhere yes so if
you do want to ask a question your need
to get his attention
I have I have one more and we're gonna
go into this I think you know there's a
there's a rabbit hole here of like what
is what is the mind and what is a person
that we need to put a pin in because I
know it's gonna it's gonna go down that
rabbit hole but we also want to address
it a little bit I mean this is not what
you are necessarily we don't know the
answer to this question because of the
work that you are doing but I think I
just want to just start with a little
bit of conversation around what you
think if you were to bring bring a brain
like this back like what do you get yeah
do we want to do the audience questions
where I we're starting with that one and
the word a microphone is gonna go around
and but I know that there's a lot in
this space and that you know we don't
have the answers to that from the
science that you were doing but I and so
but I want to get ahead of it a little
bit and say like what what do we know
what don't we know in this space all
right so I have some slides for this but
maybe we'll save them for our audience
questions but briefly the value of this
is I think two for the value of memory
preservation first I think that it's
it's obvious that being able to preserve
first-hand wisdom and first-hand
experience is useful for Humanity in
general I think one of the main problems
that we have is with every generation we
get more power and we get more
sophisticated technology and we don't
really become wiser because wisdom is
basically generated by life experience
and you're not born with more life
experience than previous generations you
are born with more powerful technology
though and that's not really sustainable
unless we figure out a way to preserve
wisdom then we're gonna have a bad time
with increasingly powerful technology
that's totally independent of any
notions of consciousness yourself or
really what's done with an individual
that's preserved beyond that I think
that you get some very interesting
questions about identity but willing
them to march towards the audience nice
all right we have a microphone so I had
a question of it seems like it's
necessary to preserve the neuron
synapses structure but how do you know
that it's sufficient how do you know
that there's not some internal structure
that gets messed up by the live
aldehydes going into the side the
synapses and messing up the actual
that's where actually the memories are
or somewhere inside they're not just in
the structure
so this so that so so this question is
like might there be something more than
synapses that matters that is being
disrupted by glutaraldehyde
in such a way that this preservation is
no longer injective it's no longer
keeping different things different and
so I guess there's a ways to go into
that but we'll keep it you know so much
right here
the first is to approach it from this
idea of injectivity it's not a question
of are there things that aren't
preserved by glutaraldehyde it's a
question of if you had two organisms
that had different memories just by one
different memory do you keep them
different or not right because if you're
preserving a book for example like
taking a photocopy of every page is
sufficient to preserve the book even
though you've abandoned quite a lot if
you are trying to preserve something and
you transform it the question of whether
the transformation preserves information
is not doesn't preserve everything it
does it keep different things different
and so we know that you have to change
synapses to encode memories and so we
also know that glutaraldehyde is able to
preserve synapses a great detail
it suggested a preserves the information
now beyond that though of course there's
a question of how easy would it be to
actually extract the information that
does depend on exactly what you're
preserving well you're not preserving
you could imagine that every neurons got
some sort of intrinsic like factor to it
that changes its sensitivity right that
you're losing a polluter aldehyde and it
could make the problem of extracting
information almost impossible to do
right certainly if you encrypt with the
road 13 you do that to these books
obviously preserves the information and
if you encrypt it with aes-256
it also clearly preserves the
information one of them is much easier
to reverse when I was basically
impossible to reverse that being said
glutaraldehyde preserves more than just
synapses right so it actually preserves
essentially all of the proteins that are
in the brain as well and so if I one of
the - one of the following two things is
true either glutaraldehyde preserves
memories and information theoretic sense
or there's a mechanism of information
storage in the brain that's
simultaneously so fragile it's destroyed
completely by glutaraldehyde fixation
but it's also so robust it survives deep
hypothermic circulatory arrest and
seizures and spreading depolarization
and concussions and MRI scans and you
rapidly get to where those aren't
overlapping sets anymore so that that's
in general how I think about it of
course the details are very important on
this and there's many many details to
think about and we have we have a
question from online which gives me a
another chance to mention that if you
are online you can submit me questions
and they get to me a little fairies and
unicorns are my little thing but Laura
from from online is asking besides brain
snapshots are there ways of preserving
the brain over time effectively a video
of the brain development it's really
tough because basically you're limited
and resolution and you want to see a
synapse you can barely see it with light
you want to resolve it better you
essentially have to dump more energy
into it to resolve it better but you
rapidly get to where
you have to dump into the system we'll
kill it if it's alive and so it's it's
almost like there's kind of a
fundamental limit for being able to
observe a living brain without damaging
it that's not even speaking about the
fact that your brain is physically quite
large and so something that could barely
resolve a synapse on the surface of the
brain if you're trying to reserve
resolve a synapse that's deep inside the
brain you've got to go through a bunch
of stuff to get it back that being said
the most plausible thing that I've ever
seen that could do something like that
is this idea of DNA self-reporting so
you change the neurons so that they
themselves record what they're connected
to and what their internal states are
and then write it into DNA and then
release that DNA into your bloodstream
and then you can sequence this vast
amount of messages that your neurons are
always reporting and use that to derive
all the connections in your brain but
that would be a very complicated gene
educating genetic engineering project
biology is like clearly capable of doing
it because it's like not particularly
more complicated what the immune system
is able to do for example in terms of
making labels and reporting on things
but you know you wouldn't be able to do
it with a stock organism I guess right
also it's like totally hypothetical it
doesn't exist and is like when I say
it's doable I mean like it would take a
generation or two to figure out how to
do it if that my favorite seventies
movie with Christopher Walken brainstorm
was really based on this concept yeah
yeah but if you wanted to see on a
scanner and a scale and probably
vaporize the brain like right so it has
the kind of a observational paradox
problem yeah pretty much
yeah because this living system and it's
you know doesn't take too kindly to
blasting it with like higher energy
photons or whatever you're trying to
impregnate with this would you be able
to retrieve wisdom and experience
independent of language
so okay I think about one what is this
doesn't always work but one heuristic
that I think of when I'm thinking about
how preservation works is just neural
networks okay so could you preserve a
deep learning neural network that
Google's made that tells cats apart from
dogs sure yeah if you write down its
geometry and you write down the weights
of the connections like you're not going
to understand what it does but certainly
you will have preserve the capability of
that neural network to just distinguish
these cats and these dogs now you can
even run this if you have an appropriate
environment you could just type in all
the code for that neural network line Li
and run it and guess what it can tell
dogs and cats are parts and a neural
network really has memories of its
training data because it can respond to
those more strongly than just any old
data and so a neural network kind of
remembers a familiarity of what it was
trained with of above and beyond an
actual ability to recognize cats versus
dogs it remembers like oh that's a
particular cat that I saw when I was
being trained however if you were to try
and figure out what the memories are the
familiarity memories are any other way
than just running the network it's
almost impossible because the network's
kind of a black box now that's a huge
active area of research the ability to
unblock box a neural network look into
it understand what the parts of it mean
independent of actually running it but
I'd say it's still an open question on
just how much you can date in the black
box and how much it's almost like
required to just run it certainly the
easiest way to get wisdom from our
preserved brain would be just simulate
the entire thing and just ask the person
what it was like to either
hey what are the primary ethical
concerns in the future that folks like
you foresee and maybe even combining
some of the things you're talking about
with AI just imagining all the data
gathering that would inherently be part
of the process and I'm just wondering if
you guys are considering ways of
addressing of those yes of question is
what are the ethical concerns when
you're preserving information um
there's that there's a few parts of this
and one person that we work with
Aundre Sandberg from the future of
humanity Institute you know we think
about the ethics of this a lot because
it's quite important to get it right
when it comes to doing preservations in
the absence of any technology to get
meaningful data from it it's it has
similar ethical problems to what you get
with embalming in general and brain
donation and so I'd say we work that out
fairly well when it comes to
safeguarding the information I would say
that the general principle to use is non
coercion and you know what's going to
enable human flourishing well so in the
case of like should you own the data
that is what defines your brain it seems
to me like if we already have HIPPA laws
that say on your like blood pressure
data certainly you would own the data
that defines your mind right I think in
addition to that you probably want
safeguards in place for someone who's
been preserved that they have control on
autonomy over when they would be
destroyed like that the sample would be
destroyed if the conditions are bad
that's something that people say is very
important I think it's very reasonable
but the general and you can do a lot of
weeds here of course it's very
complicated but the general principle is
that of autonomy right the the decisions
to the extent that can be made by the
individual
should be made by the individual so so
that that's a general fit so I don't
have had answers your question but
that's kind of how I think about it do
do we we've been talking by the brain do
we know much about how much memories
depend on the rest of the body
our memories stored in the rest of the
the neural network of our body or are we
pretty confident all we need is the
brain so the question is like what about
the body right and there's that there's
a few ways to think about this
first of all quadriplegic people exist
and when a person becomes quadriplegic
their personality isn't erased and their
memories aren't erased so clearly at
least without having a motor connection
to the body you start able to access
your memories that being said like I did
my a I thesis on embodying cognition and
I argued in the thesis that you have to
have a body to learn how the world works
and in many ways to even be able to
think at all at least a bootstrap but
it's kind of a moot point because of the
same technology that can preserve the
brain can preserve the entire body as
well so you know practically the
circulatory system extends to every cell
in the body and glutaraldehyde doesn't
really discriminate based on whether
your liver cell or a brain cell the
reason we talk about brain preservation
so much is the brain is kind of the
hardest thing to preserve so if you're
able to preserve the brain you're also
able to preserve everything else at
least a similar level of detail barring
a few stupid things that aren't we're
going into
yeah and before we we're coming up
Thanks on our last questions here and I
know you're gonna hang out and you guys
work with Robert yes his lab yes I
remember seeing you while I was down
there so there's a few other people here
in the front row that that you can
pepper with questions as well as Robert
at least as to what's going on in a lab
but I'd love for you to go through the
slides that you did bring on this kind
of question of you guys you guys want to
talk about consciousness qualia yeah
guys actually care about that's a good
way it's good way to close raise your
hand if you actually care about qualia
at all we go wow people care about okay
fine we'll talk about that so you know
alright so what about all this stuff
right so I'm gonna try a new argument
here okay I never tried this one before
I'd love feedback on how it goes okay
but I think I've more or less figured
out the anatomy of these so-called hard
problems and why they're not
particularly philosophically hygienic or
all that logical okay so the way I want
to do this is I want to introduce you to
one of the coolest things that I've ever
seen personally and then from that I
think you'll at least be able to
understand my intuition about these
problems so this is a pendulum okay it's
a computer simulation of a pendulum and
if I run this simulation it's gonna do
that
so it just has this nice harmonic motion
it does this thing it's very predictable
very concise equation of motion for this
pendulum so let's say we were to add one
single extra pendulum to it with a tiny
little weight on top of it and the
weight is only a tenth as massive as the
actual ball okay so what do you guys
think this one's gonna do this one is
this one is what we call chaos so let's
see how this one goes
remember the you know the big one it
approximates the big one it just kind of
does this thing right but you'll notice
Oh huh all right okay sure so this one's
not a regular harmonic motion this is
chaotic motion which is really cool I
guess when I was young I sort of thought
chaos was uncomputable in some way and
that you could never have a computer do
it but that's not true you know the
equation of motion for the pendulum and
they're not more complicated than the
other pendulum it's just you have a
different initial state in fact the
exact same equations did both of these
pendulums alright so it's amazing though
right seeing this thing move like this
it's almost kind of like it's got some
free will to it okay it's like it it has
some sort of whimsy in the way that it
moves and you can't predict what it's
going to do it's it's like quite
unpredictable you're not going to be
able to say oh it's gonna up here at
some point in the future or maybe it'll
end up there who knows it kind of just
does what it wants to do and the fact
that this exists is incontrovertible
obviously it has a whimsical motion to
it clearly
anybody that's denying that is why they
can't see what it's doing all right so
of course that exists but
I think there's a common philosophical
problem that people make that's very
tempting to make that's wrong all right
and that is saying look I observe this
amazing thing this whimsical motion of
this pendulum and so therefore I now
have a privileged understanding of how
the universe is organized the universe
must be a type of dumbell universe okay
you have the physical world of course
but this whimsy demands something more
it demands another world where the
whimsy lives in that somehow bridges
with this world I don't know how but it
has to be that way okay and so if you do
this then I think you've made an error
okay because the observation of
something that's amazing doesn't
automatically tell you how the universe
is organized it could be the case that
there's a world where the will of the
pendulum lives that isn't part of the
physical world and that's how that works
it could also be the case that the will
of the pendulum lives in the physical
world in a way that you might not really
quite understand but it can be in this
world and so I think in general this is
the recipe for making the so-called hard
problems all right first you observe
something that demands an explanation
something amazing okay you see red and
you see the color red it's so vibrant
you feel emotions okay you see that
there's a thing that's alive and it's
awe-inspiring and you say well because
I've observed this on spying awesome
thing I know how the world works I know
there's a special that physics can't
contain it there's a special other world
where the awesomeness lives okay and you
know you can be humble and say that you
don't know how that actually connects
and so that's the question right but now
you've by definition made your hard
problem you've said that there's a thing
that exists that physics can't explain
and so then the correlate of that is
even if you explain everything in terms
of physics you're still missing
something what about the awesomeness
okay and it's unwarranted and it's not
logical to posit that there's another
world this kind of platonic world where
these things live whether it's qualia
whether it's the vital force whether
it's freewill
you could even make a hard problem of
arithmetic you see that a calculator
when you press two buttons two and two
and you get four well sure you could say
look what I understand that the
transistors work this way but how does
it become addition right what is it that
makes the calculator do addition we all
know calculators can do addition but it
feels like if you just explain how
transistors work and how LCD screens
work that nevertheless you haven't
described the bridging laws for this
other type of platonic world where the
addition is is real and then the nasty
thing about it is I think our language
is very permissive for us to do this
automatically essentially even seeing
something like AI is already already
lost you've already posited that there's
a dual world where the eyes live and so
it's quite insidious you can make this
mistake without even realizing that
you're making this mistake and then it
traps you because anybody's saying well
but you can explain it like this with
physics well you say well are you saying
that this awesomeness isn't real because
obviously it's real I've observed it so
I think this is how you do this I think
you I think you make hard problems like
this and basically if you observe
emotions or you reserve there's a self
that's kind of monitoring yourself like
of course that's real like it's insane
to say that that's not real but it
doesn't mean that you now know how the
universe is organized it doesn't mean
there's a separate world where that
stuff lives why is it that the redness
of red has to live in its own separate
world of qualia that's divorced from how
light works why can't the redness of red
live in this world at least every time
we've done this in the past we've been
wrong okay people saw that things were
alive and so they
there must be some vital force above and
beyond mere chemistry and physics that
makes them be alive that's lost when
they die and who knows how it works but
obviously it's real just from our common
experience then we found that life is
just incredibly complicated chemistry
and it feels almost like you're cheating
or you're destroying this precious world
where the life was but the life wasn't
ever there in the first place life was
always in this world so so that's in
general I think about it but I'd love to
hear what your thoughts are well we are
actually gonna wrap up great we will
leave that for for questions after and I
want to give you a long now travelin
it's it's a timeout that means that this
is right
[Applause]
[Music]